so you mentioned on uh
the multi-stage Rockets
uh that maybe the dream would be uh if
we weren't living on Earth but maybe we
can on Earth to have a single stage uh
to orbit rocket where it's all one
package reusable it's unreasonable gets
even harder it gets even harder so first
of all what is uh just the link on it
what what is the single stage to orbit
rocket and why is it so hard to achieve
on Earth do you already kind of
explained it a little bit but just if we
were to say like yeah that's your
assignment Yeah Tim you're supposed to
get together with Elon and other
brilliant people and like you have to do
this yeah
why is it so hard why is it so hard
um it your the the payload fraction of a
rocket is
like three to five or six or seven
percent would be like you know that's
the amount of payload compared to the
total mass of the rocket like you're
lucky to get into
Beyond five percent so if you're now
having to deal with the weight of the
rocket by the time you're in orbit like
your your payload fraction just you're
you're talking about like margins it's
such
it's so small amount of leftover if you
have to take all of it with you
so the sooner you can ditch weight the
better the sooner you can ditch weight
the better the sooner you can you know
and that's what you're doing a rocket
the whole time is actually ditching
weight all of that fuel and all that big
giant flamacy is literally Mass being
thrown out the back of the rocket but
what typically is an expended you know
at least during nominal operations
you're not seeing the engines being you
know expelled out the thing until you
get to staging of course and that's
where you know you're ditching all that
dead weight so single stage to orbit
your margins just become so small that
it it's border it's not impossible but
it's just at the end of the day like
almost no matter who you are you end up
saying it's just simply not worth it
like it'd be if you have two rockets
that are using the same amount of
propellant you know they're the same
physical sizes and one of them is
cutting you know on a third and has
another little engine it'll have a
hundred or a thousand times more payload
capacity than the one sitting right next
to it
and now so there's tricks you can do to
like try to offset that things like
aerospike engines which operate at uh as
efficiently at sea level it kind of
optimized efficiency at sea level and
just by their uh by the way their design
the physics of them they're also
efficient in a vacuum too
um you can do things like that and at
the end of the day though you just end
up with a worse rocket than if you had
just done stage like no matter what and
and people say like well what if you
developed the new technologies like okay
apply that technology to a multi-stage
rocket and it's gonna do better you know
like no matter where you end up it's
just always better to ditch that weight
you know is there a cost to have a
multi-stage because you can still reuse
the different stages that's the the
dream is you know becomes easier to
reuse multiple stages because now you
know like the booster doesn't have to
survive orbital re-entry temperatures
and extreme environments and you only
have to you know make survival the upper
stage you only have to put a big heat
shield I mean starship's the perfect
perfect thing of this the upper stage
has a big giant heat shield the booster
doesn't need it because it's not going
the booster is not going to orbit it's
only going A fifth or a quarter of
orbital velocity so it's heat that it
experiences is survivable just by the
stainless steel you don't need an
additional heat shield
um so all of a sudden if you're trying
to reuse pretend that you just welded
the two stages of Starship together
remove those engines on Starship that
whole vehicle if you're trying to reuse
it the whole vehicle now has to have a
heat shield on one side of it the whole
thing has to have these big heavy Wings
by the time you come down to it there's
probably just zero payload capacity you
basically put your fuel tank in space
you know good job so the the dream of a
single stage to orbit a rocket is is
that just even the wrong dream on Earth
that's what most convention tells you
you know by the time if if you're you're
if your goal is cheap then you're going
to spend you're going to have a
physically larger rocket that has more
engines that has more propellant blah
blah to put the same amount of thing
here same amount of mass into orbit
compared to something else you know
we're talking like rocket Labs electron
a really small rocket it's like I think
1.3 meters wide and something like you
know 18 meters taller I mean it's it's a
small rocket
if you were to you know the and it can
put something like 300 and or so
kilograms into orbit
you can either launch something that
size or again like a full like big old
Falcon 9 booster the huge huge thing and
that would be lucky to put 300 kilograms
into orbit you know so it's like which
one's gonna be cheaper to build you know
ship around all this stuff and then you
also look at you have fixed costs like
the idea of flying a but this is this uh
again everything in rocket science is a
compromise because now you have things
like um people on Console time all the
people that are you know on comms and
working on the rocket going down to the
pad you know filing paperwork doing
range control making sure there's not
planes and boats in the way uh flight
termination people you have all these
fixed costs for any launch I don't care
how big the rocket is there's a
relatively fixed cost so now you say
like okay I'm gonna be paying well let's
just make them an hour I'm gonna pay
five million dollars to fly a rocket
between all the people going on site all
the propellant all the licenses blah
blah if your fixed cost is five million
dollars and you can put 300 kilograms in
Space versus you have a five million
dollar cost of operation and you can put
5 000 kilograms into space like it it's
it's the business case is going to send
you in One Direction pretty quickly